guess who's back
welcome to countless if you like it you
pay if you don't like it chance paying
anyway how much you charge for the wings
if you want to be the speech a fiance
that's gonna cost you $200 and if you
want to be Beyonce featuring jay-z then
BAM we're already oisin signal will in
every neighborhood there's a place folks
get together to talk about their dreams
to share their frustrations and maybe
even tell a joker - excuse me but I
don't like to get involved in petty
arguments yeah yeah that's primarily
what you yeah just pretty much all you
do it's a home away from home
and these aren't just friends come here
girl
they're fan check her out oh there's a
guy sit here the only man that you could
trust is the one up above each one of
y'all want a super thug that's got three
degrees from Harvard meanwhile you pass
up corny dudes like Gerard every day
don't know women Oh moist Duncan Hines
ass do like Gerard guys I'm standing
right here I can hear you
you like I don't want to target stop
playing yeah oh he'll take me too long
get back up only Rick now Knievel good
normal I'm trying to get that call in
the middle of the night saying my son is
locked up or worse some people downtown
a moving fuss we gotta fix our problems
our stuff
the barbershop is the pillar of the
neighborhood so we turn the shop into
our safe space with free cuts in styling
this one love is worth I bet he won't be
talking back to it mama no mo in the
dojo
we'll never give up your father be proud
of everything that's going on here
hashtag barbershop saves the
neighborhood is trending on Twitter can
I get a selfie with you what the my
girls want they lost did you tell me it
was awesome white people loving you go
awesome
hello my name is Erin gay by dr.
detaching physique the circus - but I
like buildings